I've known a lot of dudes who will judge
and just not even they'll just
pre-select who wins because that's their
friend
yeah they don't even care wow say their
name yeah
[Music]
do you guys know what's going on in the
Irish dancing world right now
yes I don't know is it I could just
imagine Steve finding this article last
night and it's like I can't wait to Tee
It Up to these [ __ ] guys well dancers
she's a dancer too yeah Irish dancing
river dancing is it I got it I'm not
even a dancer ding ding ding I can do
that [ __ ] right I don't know every Irish
dancer is like not the same thing you
know the dance community's not talking
about the Irish dancing somehow we're
blocked out from this gossip oh wow
somehow maybe someone's trying to save
us how would you guys so if you guys
were cheating at dancing which I think
one of you has done before I won't say
who I clearly cheated to be second place
[Laughter]
it's harder to do Anthony Lee was
stealing votes how would you cheat at
dancing cheat at dancing like the real
way like you're wearing like double
shoes or some [ __ ] double shoes you
gotta Grease the judges I don't know
like how do you how do you cheat at this
you gotta grease how would you cheat at
your type of dancing and my type of
dancing
probably extra shoes take muscle
relaxers and you're like [ __ ]
actually
but so relaxer
I think you'd have to do some do
something to your competitive
yeah oh yeah yeah like Tonya Harding
that [ __ ] right Tyler's shoelaces
together yeah while they're dancing
laxative in the monster
take the batteries out of the lights
before they perform yo laxative in the
monster might be fire dude yeah in a
Monster yeah laxative would be yeah
Ex-Lax
I don't know what's it I mean other than
like you know greasing the judges or
some [ __ ] yeah that's the kind of thing
or maybe like uh right before our
competitors just like putting oil on the
[ __ ] stage so ding ding ding that's
what's going on right now there's
allegations of competition fixing and
cheating in the Irish dancing Community
sick oh that's uh you know what though
drama it means more in that Community
because Irish dancing is more of a
cultural route like they'll that shit's
been around you think we ain't got
culture hundreds of years though so you
think they need something to spice it up
or something technically not even
allowed to do what we do yeah we'll get
in trouble depending on who you talking
about yeah oh because it's like you're
you're ripping off somebody's culture
we're only allowed to do derivatives of
shenyoon
which is a lot of variety great
marketing by the way which is thousands
of years back so the Irish dancing
commission a governing body known as
known in Irish as I don't [ __ ] care
[Laughter]
you should care I don't has appointed a
former judge to investigate claims that
prominent dance schools and teachers
have rigged competitions it has emerged
this week it was it is alleged that at
least 12 teachers in Ireland and other
countries conspired to ensure certain
dancers scored highly in international
tournaments known as who gives a [ __ ]
International Irish tournaments yep wait
that sucks only because
um if a teacher or like a uh you know a
staff member or whatever it's if it's
not like the kids or like the team's
fault you know what I mean if it's like
they're directors and whatnot then that
like can totally [ __ ] up their entire
experience right and their perception of
their self-worth as a dancer right
pretty brutal but they're doing it so
they can get more funding that's the
reason why they're doing it dude oh I
think so right because our teams win
everything and they win everything they
get way more funding so they should be
doing that did second place win a lot of
money never
did you guys get a lot of money no not
after taxes
um and you gotta split like [ __ ] 75
dances
yeah eight ways yeah God damn
75 dances son of a [ __ ] isn't it
that's crazy does it admission uh like
the age of the dancers or like what that
bracket of competition or no it just
tries to tell me a bunch of [ __ ]
Irish words I don't give a [ __ ] about
Irish words yeah it's like are they
still written in English it's like these
are international tournaments are known
as fish Hannah
and it's like okay yeah it's it's actual
language right what is it called
Gaelic Gaelic one of my clients speaks
Gaelic and I was like one why two why
who do you speak it to yeah who exactly
who do you conversate with and then he
was showing me some words and I was like
yo this is crazy does it go to like the
Renaissance Fair every year I don't
think so what's up what's the Gaelic
word I wish I could tell you really
oh well that is English dude I don't
know but he says it fast and it becomes
one word I know English when I hear it
and that's English Steve are you you're
Irish right are you a little Irish I'm a
little bit Irish Colleen are you a
little Irish as well I'm not okay lucky
I asked you guys yesterday and you guys
told me everything and I forgot but do
you know any like
Irish deep cut stuff like from your
history
I know about the IRA car bombings I
don't know what my stance is on it okay
because I don't know anything about it
yeah that's true I think probably
carbon's bad yeah probably yeah but I
don't know I don't know what their
politics is or anything like that is
what I'm getting at like I don't know
what so you're saying you think the IRA
is connected to this dance cheat bro I
think they're connected to [ __ ]
everything in Ireland because I don't
know much about it I don't think
anything moves the IRA is deep in the
pockets of the dance are they like the
Irish mafia and government put together
all right I think it's all in one I only
know about the IRA through Sons of
Anarchy and they sell guns through
Hell's Angels so same I only know about
it through media [ __ ] like like movies
and stuff like like watching like peaky
blinders yeah like one of the Harrison
Ford Tom Clancy movies had some fugitive
yeah fugitive I think no I don't know
[Music]
well they got to maintain that because
they are the IRA right there you go I
literally don't know they got to go
these guys see that's the thing about
Irish stuff like we should dive a little
deeper in it no no dive deeper into
dance stuff please yeah but through
Irish and then we go back we backtrack
through dance Irish dance you know so so
apparently um they're the allegations
are uh quote such unethical Behavior
cannot and will not be tolerated by this
organization and and they're trying to
make sure that they have like
re-established fairness and transparency
because not everyone's like questioning
like this dance body what's fair though
that's interesting I mean there are just
judges that just choose what they
[ __ ] choose regardless right they're
subjective there's just bad judges yeah
with it it was really just getting
greased like the judging people were
just getting money on the side therefore
they were making calls yep 12 teachers
were requesting our offering to fix
competitions and that was discovered by
the governing body whoa
I wonder what like the price is like if
I'm like a judge I'm just out of
curiosity you know I wouldn't do this
what would be your price let's say
you're judging a dance show well it's a
big dance show someone goes here's a
thousand bucks can you swing it the
other way is it a televised answer or a
community dance show televised well it's
more worthy televised I feel like
televised you can't do that you know
what I mean you're gonna get caught how
would you know how would they know it's
just your opinion all right what if it's
one of those
um those like giant competitions was
like a thousand Studios send their kids
out guys because those are the ones that
can benefit from cheating because their
studio will gain popularity and more
students come in and that also those
competitions oftentimes are like three
days and you're doing like all these age
categories and you're just spending 12
hours just judging [ __ ] hunches and
numbers so you also have way less care
almost you start desensing desensitizing
yourself to like the humans you're just
like watching the next school so you
don't have relationships you're just
kind of like what's your price what's
your price
say there's 12 rounds
come on let [ __ ]
the amount of money in the dance
Community is already so little and we
get paid so little to judge so I think
it was pretty low it's like ten dollars
that's a good answer 300 that's true 300
bucks no not more than that for sure
I think uh I think I could get greased
for like 20 grand
wow I think these Studios have that
money though well I just need to be able
to buy my plane ticket and get away and
you know into a non-ess tradition Island
because the dance company is crazy
they're connected to the IRA they can
find me
good point will it be a good way for
them to pay you the 20 G's without uh
tracking without like if people were to
like scrutinize they'd be like do I have
Joe helping me or is it just by myself
no not yet Joseph I don't know if he's
gonna buy the plane for me and then
again no no no he's in he's in Hawaii
Dude planes are 30 grand I think yeah
well I mean the way that we've always
done it when we do International stuff
is we take cash and we split it amongst
the homies and then everybody carries it
back in their bags period oh isn't that
scary so that's why you have a lot of
kinjas so you guys could run [ __ ]
fast I'm on Quest Crew dude if the IRA
is subscribed I'm Quest Crew the easiest
way would have just been for them to buy
fake digital classes from you guys
because there's no proof that you even
like redeem them yeah wow send them a
fake invoice that's a good way to move
money Brian's wild why are you so
experienced why do you know this sorry
that's smart how's it got answers just
on depth for all the shady [ __ ] do you
think that as Joe's doing the stupid
plain bit Ryan's just sitting there like
because that's actually for the sake of
comedy of just going along with it but
I'm like come on
he's like I know a guy on Fiverr that
could do it like I was like that's not
how you that's not how you want Coke
yeah all right damn that's actually
pretty genius dude don't do it though
any of you guys do you know anybody
who's uh [ __ ] cheating in some damn
[ __ ] in our world uh not for you know
what's funny not for money but just for
like because that's your homie
I've known a lot of dudes who will judge
and just not even they'll just
pre-select who wins because that's their
friend and they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
they don't even watch the battle they're
just like this yeah they don't even care
wow say their name yeah
you think that's worse and that's not me
that's not me like just going oh I have
a feeling it's like no like there
they've said I don't give a [ __ ] is
that at a local level competition that's
local [ __ ] okay so it is a local level
but to to these dancers there is no
difference whether it's TV local like
your neighborhood sock hop it's that
respect is equal to anything plus if you
don't win your local stuff you can't
even get qualified into some of the
bigger stuff sometimes that like
actually has you know like um some sort
of sponsorship or TV backing you know
what I mean they're all they're already
like cherry picking selecting stuff
anyway yeah I have some uh like power
lifting reference and then so in the way
like a powerlifting meet Works don't be
like 10 20 people competing just kind of
like any any like uh almost sport where
there's like there's 10 people on the
track racing only the first three are
going to get medals the other seven if
they just don't get disqualified or snap
an ankle they're pretty happy just to be
there so power lift things like that too
and then so
um if we if like my gym or my our team
goes and then the ref can tell that oh
this person is just brand new or
whatever and she's not even gonna meddle
or do anything like that just to kind of
give them like motivation so like for us
it's like if you the squad has to hit a
certain depth and then the the ref will
give him like a white light like the ref
will literally like the squad was a
little bit higher hit the white light
and look at me and like smile real quick
thank you but it's just thick we just
tell it oh it's just for a beginner it's
just like it's just to pass them on to
the next level I'm like that's all right
so you don't like get all sad at your
very first power level when we judge
Junior competitions a lot of times the
judges will get together and stuff and
we'll be like hey what's everybody's
lowest score yeah that they're gonna
give they'll be like all right nobody go
if it's like out of 10 or out of 100
like nobody go under the 50. yeah
otherwise like you definitely always
have that person's like this sucks and
they're just actually grading in their
mind objectively yeah but then it's like
if you don't have Olympic style scoring
already in place where you're dropping
the highest the lowest score or
something like that then this person one
person and that's their truth of judging
and it crushes them though destroys
somebody well what if you guys pick a
set like lowest score and then somebody
does not bring it at all
and they're getting the lowest score and
that's like the charity for them to be
like oh dude 50 is good for you it makes
sense because you still want to be
constructive like these teams can get
better but they're just going to
dismantle themselves if you just go you
guys have no [ __ ] hole like plus it's
not as objective like let's say with and
this is my assumption let's say
something with like power lifting her
it's like if they lifted this many
pounds and they did it this many times
it's like a stat it's a number it's like
recorded but like with dance it's half
of it is so subjective anyway it's like
your opinion so even when a team could
be like super technically sound but you
could be like but I like this artistic
Choice better so I'm gonna give this
higher points and then that's like
unarguable you know what I mean because
there's such a 50 physicality to it and
like such a fifty percent just are
artistic ability or creative choices and
then the judges kind of have that leeway
to to choose their preferences way more
gray area for us how do you tell a kid
though it's like hey you're just not
[ __ ] serving
you tell them you tell them hey you
tried really good and then you tell
their coach and this kid's not doing
good oh okay that foundation of the
lowest score is like the the equivalent
to a participation award yeah that hurts
my feelings
[Music]